Be sure to turn on
your electronic devices
in order to fully enjoy the experience.
The story of Tales of the City
is one of quiet revolution.
Whatcha doin'?
Feeling the vibes of fiery resistance
seeping into my skin.
We find we're able to still
push the conversation forward,
extending it to the younger generation.
And it's the opportunity of a lifetime
to come back to something that was truly
a formative experience for me.
People have been talking about bringing
Tales back over the past 25 years.
But the reason for it being redone
had to be in response
to the world we're living in now.
A couple of queers walk down the street
and no one knows it. Are they still queer?
Barbary Lane is a magical place
that exists a little outside
the real world.
You'll find I'm not particularly
literal about these things.
Literal's for the unimaginative.
Action!
Just as Barbary Lane is a safe place
for our characters,
I wanted the show to be a safe space
for viewers.
Inherently, within towns, there is a sense
of family and a sense of home.
It's got a little community.
These friendships and relationships
are all about letting you be the person
who you wanna be.
What's up, millennial?
Do not ever call me that again.
Generations that seem light years away
actually can reach common ground
and understand each other.
It's just a matter of listening.
So, it's time to regroup and show again
how a loving community
can become a family.
What do you think is up there?
Rich white people.
A lot of the season is structured around
Anna Madrigal and a flashback to 1966.
A secret that she has.
Comptons was basically
the Rosa Parks bus of trans history.
Girls, this is Anna.
We see Anna's experience
juxtaposed against these trans women
that she falls into.
Those men, the ones you drink
and dance with,
those men are killing us one by one.
Predominantly, marginalized people,
in some ways,
potentially being rejected
from their family,
you know, have to form their own family.
This feels too good to be true.
My mother used to say,
-"There's only the truth."
-There's only the truth.
In any community,
race, culture, class, all of it,
it shows that we can all be different
and still experience the same things.
A new generation.
Isn't it beautiful
and also terribly depressing?
Terribly.
The books and the series
are such cult classics.
This is surreal.
I produced the original in 1994.
We were making a love letter
to San Francisco
and a love letter to a new, all-embracing,
nonjudgmental version of family.
For the viewer,
I think, it just widens their perspective.
I think it's especially good
for younger people
and makes their humanity more inclusive.
You don't wish for what's to come.
You revel in what's already here.